[Music]
ready to go
okay
we look for any contraband agriculture
products narcotics
money instruments of terror anything
like that prohibited from the united
states
so this morning we had an express
consignment flight arrive from germany
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to utilize our canine and we're
physically
going to inspect the packages and see
what we come up with guys let's just lay
these out in a straight line
we have to work quickly because a lot of
the packages are overnight or two days
shipping so we have only a short time
before they need to arrive at their
destination
all right bring them in
bach is trained on narcotics meth
ecstasy
heroin cocaine marijuana and hash and
now fentanyl
an alert on this package over here let's
take take it out let him keep going
ah taco boy good boy
all right good boy good to go we'll do
an exam on this table over here
[Music]
looks like we've got two toy cars
a little bit of weight to it
bingo
feels like pills all right
let's take a look
and yes pills square pills different
colors
we don't know what it is until we get a
field test we don't know what it is
we have a positive response for ecstasy
the total weight is 114 grams
these pills look like pez candy child
gets a hold of them
and one pill ingested could be a fatal
or fatal dose
we'll wrap it up we'll make the phone
call to hsi which is our investigative
unit
and they will find out who's ordering
this who's distributing this
and ultimately we want to put them in
jail
[Music]
you